i'm gavrie i'm dennis he's my
ex-boyfriend
ex-girlfriend
we did it for about two years over two
years two years ago over two years
broken up for like two months
i have
yeah i think i have to
sus
um dennis is like on the quiet side he
needs someone with a lot of personality
i feel like
because i don't know if he's editing or
i don't know if he doesn't speak much
but
not a lot he's giving me whipped
[Music]
my vibes
this is not going to go well yes
[Laughter]
you can't go out with a prettier [ __ ]
with me mm-hmm
i'm not going to allow it yeah allow it
fam she's not gonna
god damn
i don't [ __ ] been doing a lot
with the lashes
take flight
listen listen
if bird woman wants to do anything
better
[Music]
isn't it funny the girl before goes
you're really pretty
sometimes
not saying anything is saying way more
yeah just swipe yeah don't need all
these explanations because you're making
a bunch of other people feel like trash
but i digress you live your best life
it's hot
i'm chilling
hi hello
i'm liz the first thing i noticed was
your crocs oh my gosh
do i love them thank you
she wore crocs to a date
this is l.a
but
i used to live in l.a
the only reason you should be wearing
crocs to date is because somebody broke
into your car and stole all your shoes
that is the only reason my name is
gabrielle
that's awkward what's your name my name
is gabriella but i go by gabriel allison
my name is brianna but i go by ria are
you nervous at all so
he's nervous too [ __ ] you can't talk
is this a rule that i'm not
understanding cause right now it feels
like she's auditioning for like one of
her girlfriends she wants her a date
with one of her friends yes dude you
know you don't talk maybe it's the
editing but
i don't know i feel like it's cool like
i feel like a lot of people can't
imagine being in the same space as their
ex oh what do you do right now i go to
ucla and i study design media arts so
i'm doing like graphic design um
i want her
you know what it is i hate about young
women
their voices are just so full of
optimism
like they ain't had to pay taxes
you want someone that's dead inside not
dead inside
someone that said
i don't want to wake up tomorrow
you know what i mean a few days
and i'm saying
you know what i mean
yeah
or someone who looked at their
co-workers just struggling at work
through a grueling experience and be
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] i'm calling in
sick you know what i mean i need
somebody by my side who's a little bit
unscrewed you know scrupulous you know
what i'm saying
understand how to you know have to make
ends meet struggle you want to go out do
you want to go out uh tonight yeah i
don't want to deal with none of them
boosters
all right yeah or something you mean
you're like yeah what you want to do
this weekend nothing that's [ __ ] sexy
yeah you want to do nothing [ __ ] man
let's do nothing together that is one of
the sect i need that the young woman got
too much i want someone who's outgoing
and oh my days
this girl wanna do activities
ugh
something about young women energy just
just turned me right off you know what
i'm saying
you want to go look at the [ __ ]
little little elves sinking for santa
this weekend
you know what to do damn [ __ ] them
dweebs
them short people bro
nah i don't know trying to see that [ __ ]
no you don't you want to go like check
out santa no
does that make me the grinch
i look like the grinch yes yes but i i
get i get what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah and you know what else i don't like
about young woman yeah i'm not just
it's like they have too many dreams
hopes and aspirations yes
but i'm not mad at that because i think
you had that but they're like too
optimistic about it you know i mean they
believe in it too much without like
and i think there's a beauty to that
yeah there's a beauty to that they don't
know because you just go out to the
world you just try a bunch of [ __ ] you
notice i'm not mad at that but they
don't know but i'm like you haven't hit
the wall yet no yes and you gonna hit
the wall they don't know who's about to
smack you oh yeah reality's about to
tell you we're real bad [ __ ] you got no
tablets you're not the ones it's time
for you to switch majors that happens
sometimes okay all right so it's just
like more often than it's just like this
is like
there's a feeling for me while i'm just
sitting back and i'm like
i've already passed the wall did my
therapy have to reckon with it and i'm
not trying to sit through you having to
go through that [ __ ] and having your
midlife crisis
so i'ma pass you you you want
a realistic [ __ ] someone that
knows it's not gonna happen yeah you
still have this idea that we're gonna do
activities together for the rest of our
lives like no no it's not gonna happen
hiking mm-hmm boo-boo going on top of
that that's how women disappear
wake up define things like that he's the
graphic designer that's super cool so i
actually make wigs um yes and i'm really
into fashion i love fashion
is music like a big thing for you like
if i find out someone's music taste it
can tell me a lot about themselves who
are your top three the weeknd always mac
miller and kanye i have a mac miller
tattoo are you serious divine feminine
right here yeah oh my god wait let's
make you wanna know
show me your tattoo no show me yours
dude
you can get up and walk the [ __ ] off
i was like if you were to see dennis on
a dating app would it have been a left
or right be honest we could pretend like
he's not here
i'm not sure
whoa that's saucy
goddamn pretend he's not here like on
the real tell him he's ugly like oh
yeah yeah
yeah
whoa
i have to walk that [ __ ] off
i have to walk that [ __ ] off i can
understand
fatality
flawless victory
humble breaker
[Laughter]
i would have probably gone right
you know it mostly did depend on like
our conversation
thank you
did you hear what she said
if you saw him on a data profile would
you swipe left or right this flight
brush and she said i would have swiped
right but like depending on the
conversation you only get a conversation
if you swipe right that means no
that means no
we already know
come on breath
rep she was trying to be nice which is
understandable the dude is right in
front of her face
mm-hmm
it was a very like complicated
relationship so it most of the time felt
like i was alone so i would just say it
was already i get it you get it
is this a game of sabotage or let me
help you
because since the beginning i don't
think she handed him a single alley-oop
another single one
listen my man's just taking it down
he's taking it lying down
he's not fighting to be fair he's on the
bench he's not even playing
uh booboo if he's on the bench then why
is he on the floor
he's not on the bench
how you benched and on the floor i mean
he gotta put how are you on the bench
and getting posters he's not on how are
you getting posterized not running
no how are you getting posterized
in you on the bench that does not make
any sense i understand what you're
saying but
my man is catching straight bullets and
he's not even part of the fight
you know what this is like
this is like having your mom write your
dating profile oh man okay oh man all
those arranged marriages poo i blame you
yeah you know when your mom comes like i
know this cute girl and she's never cute
oh man this is this oh it's really just
you're not your type
just saying all right it was nice
meeting you beautiful and bye have a
good one and beautiful on your bike
goodness meeting you
am i going this way okay
shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up you might not be clingy
but god damn you need to shut the [ __ ]
up
[Music]
okay sounds good
um
red hair yes
one next to you yes
[Music]
it's nice meeting you guys
bye
no offense to none of these girls but
she picked the elise threatenings
alison okay allison right off the bat
what are your reservations like about
dennis like from what you observed i
felt like i spoke more to you than i
spoke to him
[ __ ] cause you can't shut the [ __ ] up
what are your reservations about dennis
who
oh yeah i thought it was a deal with you
who's dennis dennis
the guy who was holding your purse
i thought he was the the sound guy but
yeah i mean it is a very new environment
so i don't think it's his fault
did you say that you would swipe left or
right on him i don't think he's my
normal type so i think if i just saw him
like on tinder probably a left probably
left yeah fine press pause
that's fine because you're not trying to
set him up
oh my days
okay if your ex comes around start
asking you about your dating life who
you dating what's your profile don't
don't be answering none of that [ __ ]
don't let her sabotage nothing okay and
every if you're excellent i've had girls
do this before we did and then they try
to set me up with somebody else don't
don't don't
you ever had this had i've had this
happen to me really touch me girl i'm
like yay
is she very attractive i think she's
cute
i feel like we're going on a date i know
i was like i'm nervous
you saw dennis yes like when i talked to
him he seemed like pretty fine you know
what i mean oh i was like
just like fine like i would like to talk
to more okay but if i'm being totally
honest he is like he just like switched
his major and stuff so he is kind of in
that phase of figuring stuff out is that
something that kind of like you wouldn't
want to be involved with in a sense
actually funny because like i switched
my major at my college recently so i was
like oh my god am i behind in life i
think every day we have something we can
like improve on to mature ourselves and
like he's on his own journey too because
i have no right to be like oh my god he
speeded up a little bit
no i know the last girl yeah the red
head the lord
[Music]
that's like my biggest thing right now
i'm like trying to up my game i wear a
lot of vintage t-shirts that's what i
wear a lot of i never asked like but why
did you and gabriel break up so we broke
up twice actually uh the first time
well it was my first like long
relationship so i was like i went in
kind of blind i feel like she taught me
a lot of things and then but yeah i
think we broke up because i felt like i
was we were always with each other and
we didn't know how to balance stuff out
so i've only been in one long
relationship and it was for like a
little more than a year and for me it
was literally the same issue like we
were together so often and we kind of
just created like a codependency with
each other which i really just could not
do
can't have that
you know what chill with
two of my girl all the time yeah
all the
some couples are like that though oh
future i mean some couples personal
instagram is just a couple's one yeah
like they got two instagrams but [ __ ]
it's just one times two i can't do it
yeah
you can't do it yeah they'd be posting
each other all the time they'd be all
over each other all the time like that's
a lot of proximity bruh another [ __ ]
fool what would your choice have been i
chose you like really okay you know what
i think it's because of that
no literally i was like that's so cool
because she pointed at your hand and i
was like
same tattoo i thought it was just good
oh my god
okay um ig
perfect nice oh i see the face oh that's
cool okay put on our greatest fits
exactly we'll see who's better at it
[Music]
i will of course
yeah i'm watching that [ __ ] i want to
watch part two revenge yeah
but you know what maybe not he might
actually just pick some guys that are
very attractive for who knows but she
definitely sabotaged oh yeah that's
happened
yeah and guess what it's gonna be him
picking for her she's going to talk the
whole time
if it's me
i look like an airbender [ __ ] just like
this
just just
i'll be pushing them all to the left
your move came from that's what you
deserve man
[Laughter]
avatar the last airbender i'm blowing
all these [ __ ] to the left pause
pause big puss
pause that was
kind
but anyways i digress
i digress you know listen they started
talking at the end seemed like they had
a bit of chemistry who knows
but i really feel sorry good lord
anything else you want to say nah all
right let us know what you guys think in
the comments